we're joined now by professor david
nabarro he's a special envoy
to the world health organization on
covert he reports
directly to the director general
professor
welcome to spectator tv uh
36.5 million cases
of covert across the globe over a
million
fatalities are we past the worst or not
can we
can we see an end to this yet or not
thank you very much andrew and i'd like
to greet you and greet everybody
sorry for being a bit late to go
straight to the question
uh no we're not past the worst of it uh
i've i
my own view is this virus is actually
towards the beginning of its
relationship with the human race
uh our estimates suggest that
possibly as many as 10 of the human
population
so far have been exposed to it there's
still
90 percent of the human population an
awful lot of people
who are susceptible to it so we're
saying
that uh we really do have to learn how
to coexist
with this virus in a way that doesn't
require
constant closing down of economies
but at the same time in a way that
is not associated with high levels of
suffering and death
it's what we're calling the middle path
and the middle path
is about being able to hold the virus
at bay whilst keeping economic and
social life
going and we think it's doable but we
also think that it requires a really
high
level of organization by governments and
remarkable degree of uh engagement by
the people
both of which in some countries is
proving to be quite difficult
indeed i want to come on to that now i'm
fascinated by that how you describe it
as the middle way and who's doing it
right and and who should
take more interest in the middle wave of
professor but
let me ask you this because you take a
global view of these things
am i right in saying that at the end of
the day
we didn't really have a proper global
response to this that
that individual countries in the end
they went their own way
would that be unfair or is that accurate
no it's totally right
actually it's explicable firstly this is
a brand new virus
it's absolutely not like any other virus
that those of us who've been involved in
infectious diseases
have encountered before even the sars
virus of 2003 was different from this
one
and and because it's new we're learning
about it all the time
so it's not surprising that quite a lot
of government
said well the who is having to learn
about it
and they don't really know so we'll go
our own way as well
and we've already heard even on this
program that
uh there are quite wide variations
my own view is the debt short-sighted if
you're dealing with
a common enemy and this virus doesn't
change whether it's
in britain or in bahrain it's still the
same virus we should surely be working
on it together
but the reality is it's been a
remarkably
uncoordinated and disjointed response
tell me more about this middleware you
were talking about because
as we look back we can see when the
pandemic began to gather speed
most major economies went for a lockdown
and
and people accepted that but there was a
real fear of the unknown we don't know
much about this
this seems to be the the right way for
we better do that
and then we you know by we i don't just
mean britain i mean france spain
even america and other countries too
outside
the western hemisphere they began to
pull back a bit from lockdown
and it seemed to be that we were getting
a little bit back to normality and then
the cases started to rise and the
instinct of governments was then to
move back not necessarily to national
lockdowns but to a variety of different
kind of
of lockdowns people are now beginning to
think if this
is the right response that that uh
we know more about this virus now than
we did before we know
it's rarely fatal for young people but
it is
often fatal for those who are over 70s
and maybe what we've learned now ought
to inform our policy
yeah is that the middle way well it it's
almost
i'm i'm not going to go on long long
because you'll cut me anyway but
here it goes the middle way is really
trying to make certain that we put in
place
robust defenses against this virus so
that if it does start to build up
anywhere
we can catch it quickly and we can
suppress
outbreaks fast to do that
we need really two things one is very
well organized
localized uh infectious disease control
services sometimes they're called public
health services
it's not hospitals but it is testing
contact tracing and isolation the
backbone to controlling this kind of
thing
is always testing contact tracing and
isolation
the second part of it is involving local
actors
as much as possible because trying to do
dealing with small
spikes of disease is best done locally
it's not best done from some central
control
center and thirdly it works best if
people as
on-side as they possibly can be it does
mean
really leveling with people saying
actually the only way we can do this
is all of us pulling together physical
distancing
face protection hygiene isolating if
we're ill not going off to work or to
the pub
if we're feeling rotten and protecting
those who are most at risk
if we can combine those various steps
what we call
doing it all in in our organization
speak
then we can get on top of it that's what
east asian countries have done
indeed germany is doing pretty well
uh uh took a good effect that's what
parts of canada are doing
and that's the approach that we believe
should be adopted we think
lockdowns only serve one purpose and
that is
to give you a bit of breathing space so
you
just stop everything the virus stops
moving and while you've got that
breathing space you should be
really building up your testing building
up your contact tracing
building up your local organization so
that as you release
lockdown you're bound to get more cases
but you can do with it
really really elegantly at the moment
western europe's not quite there but it
could get there
and i actually have a lot of hope for
ireland i've done a lot with uh
dr houlihan and his team and i think
there's a they've got a good chance
actually
of being able to do it hopefully without
having to do another lockdown but just
localized movement restrictions
well what did what did you make of the
irish politician the irish government
saying to his scientific advisors no
we're not going to do that
it's right that there should be
interplay
between the public health doctors and
government in the end government has to
take responsibility
for balancing what might be seen as
the trade-off between health and the
economy
our line is to say let that be temporary
what we want you to do because this
virus is going to be around for quite a
long time to come
is work out how you can keep the economy
going
and keep the numbers of disease cases
down and i suspect that's what's going
to happen as a result of this latest
wobble they'll find an accommodation and
county by county
alan will get on top of this virus it's
happening i think already from what i'm
picking up from colleagues
the only thing to watch out for is that
sense among the public that they're
being pulled around too much
yes and they don't do what they're asked
to do
yes and then the rules have seemed to
have got more in the early days lockdown
rules were pretty you may not have liked
them but they were quite simple to
follow
then now you kind of you take a notebook
around with you when the prime minister
doesn't even know
what they are then maybe the rest of us
don't necessarily know what they are
but you know sorry professor and you go
andrew just one thing you know this is
so
new this terrible virus it's not nice
it's horrible it's it's dangerous and
it's uh
cunning this virus is so new to humanity
we're only uh nine months into it really
if you
if you think of how long it's been in
europe i think it'll take us
quite a lot more weeks to really work
out how we're going to live with this
virus what balance of risk we're
prepared to tolerate
and also how we will collectively
organize ourselves
but i reckon that early next year we'll
be feeling much more comfortable and it
will become second nature but right now
it's a bit stumbling in the dark we
we sometimes balk at the lockdown
because it's yet another lockdown we
thought
we'd all be over there by this by
september uh october
it's also as i said it gets very
complicated and so on but these are
quite
narrow um personal inconveniences and
and of course they can have economic
impacts
uh overall too but we had professor
sunetra
uh gupta from oxford university on and
she was implying and i'm interested in
you because you have a global mandate a
global view
but a problem we don't think about in
lockdowns is that they're very
nationalistic
that if we lock down our economy then it
hits our economy
but it also means we are not buying
stuff we're not trading with weaker
economies we are
not just destroying our own jobs we're
destroying the jobs of all those that
in the poorer parts of the world that
export to us that
seemed to me to be a reasonable point
really important point by professor
gupta i want to say it again
we in the world health organization do
not
advocate lockdowns as a primary means of
control of this virus
the only time we believe a lockdown is
justified
is to buy you time to reorganize regroup
rebalance your resources protect your
health workers who are exhausted
but by and large we'd rather not do it
just look at what's happened to the
tourism
industry for example in the caribbean or
in the pacific
because people aren't taking the
holidays looks what's happened to
smallholder farmers all over the world
because their markets have got dented
look what's happening to poverty levels
it seems that we may well have a
doubling of world poverty
by next year we may well have at least a
doubling of child malnutrition because
children are not getting
meals at school and their parents in
poor families
are not able to afford it this is a
terrible ghastly global
catastrophe actually and so we really do
appeal to all world leaders
stop using lockdown as your primary
control method
develop better systems for doing it work
together
and learn from each other but remember
lockdowns just have one
consequence that you must never ever uh
belittle
and that is making poor people an awful
lot poorer
indeed and horizon world poverty after
years and years in which world poverty
was falling and falling
you